one thing female lions do is synchronize  their reproductive cycles its period  yeah it's it's basically the same thing  there's several mothers at once they  help take care of each other's cubs so  they're actually really good at  synchronizing the time they go into  estrus so you've got a lot of females at  the same time ready to mate that means  they'll have Cubs within a few days or a  few weeks of each other the advantages  one there's a lot more females to help  protect the Cubs so group defense and  also there's several females like taking  at once  so they can first nurse each other's  Cubs  you all have the same goal which is to  raise your offspring to make sure that  your DNA gets passed on and so it's an  added advantage to everybody in the  group  a male has a really good-looking many  females were crazy over it  Lions actually have to be in a really  good physical condition to produce that  dark hair on a name